are there potential photos that exist
that show
occupants
in some of these quote-unquote craft
well there's a lot of photos that show a
lot of things the question is are they
real are they legitimate
um you know uh are there potential
photos that have potentially deemed as
legitimate that have that quality
um
there are very compelling photos out
there that seem to show something inside
some sort of occupancy
and i'll leave it at that because it
it's it's it gets really murky much
beyond that
um
and there's a lot that can can be
speculated and so i try to avoid
speculation as much as possible but yes
um i've spoken to enough people
firsthand knowledge that that
not only report the crafts that we we
know exist but but potentially
some sort of
intelligence inside these these vehicles
he's mentioned to get to murky murky as
in low resolution or murky what do you
mean by murky
i mean in every every aspect
the source of the information how the
information was obtained under what
circumstances
resolution of photographic evidence all
of it
and so that's why we have to be very
careful